now it's really important to recognize  that a language is not just vocabulary  or grammar a language is a flash to the  human spirit it's a vehicle through  which the soul of each particular  culture comes in the material world  every language is an old-growth forest  of the mind of water should have thought  an ecosystem of social spiritual  psychological ecological possibilities  and to lose half the languages in  generation is to literally lose half of  humanity's collective knowledge because  the importance of a language is not a  correlate of the number of people who  speak it the importance of a language is  the fact that by definition it is a  branch in the human tree that goes back  for multiple generations  [Applause]